[Musique]
avec tous ces canadiens qui se trouvent
dans les zones dévastées est ce que le
canada a l'obligation légale d'aller les
chercher on ne vérifie
[Musique]
la réponse c'est non
le canada n'est pas obligé d'évacuer ce
qui se trouve soit dans des zones où il
ya eu des catastrophes naturelles ou
encore là où il ya des guerres le site
du gouvernement est claire la décision
de voyager relève de vous seul
c'est également à vous seul qu'il
incombe de veiller à votre sécurité
personnelle à l'étranger vous devez
d'abord essayé de quitter la région où
vous vous trouvez par vos propres moyens
par des vols commerciaux par exemple et
par la suite en dernier recours
le canada pourrait vous évacué vers le
lieu le plus sûr alors pas
nécessairement vers le canada mais vers
le lieu le plus sûr et ce n'est pas
nécessairement gratuit ottawa peut
réclamer des frais d'évacuation mais
pour cette fois
le gouvernement n'en verra pas de
facture aux évacués si vous avez besoin
d'assistance à l'étranger c'est votre
responsabilité vous enregistrer alors la
façon la plus simple de le faire c'est
en écrivant un courriel affaires
mondiales canada qui va vous contacter
si vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque
chose
écrivez nous